for the delaying start with regards to
technical issues we've had
so uh i'll be acting as being
facilitator just to do the
introductory bet and the uh election
chairman
and then that will pretty much end the
meeting so if members have any technical
difficulties during the meeting
please contact katie brewer her number
is 577046 and that will be at the top of
the chapter
for amendment if you need it uh for
those of us uh who are watching by the
country's youtube stream please follow
the instructions below
below the video if there are any issues
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please meet your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help
everyone listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be
on if the participant has been granted
permission to speak to gain permission
to speak please briefly indicate in the
chat to the right-hand side of the
screen
and we'll make a note and go back to you
once the person has finished speaking
but everyone please sure that their
mobile phone is turned to silent and
it's not used to make or receive phone
calls market meetings in progress
and please also refrain from checking
emails or conducting other business and
ensure that you're in a quiet room for
even distractions
situational meeting please note that the
meeting is being live streamed remember
the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
the live streaming and recording of the
meeting will immediately cease from the
point of the press on public are
excluded from the meeting
if that was the case but it's not this
time so
looking at attendance please can i ask
everybody who's in attendance to
uh confirm when i read out your name
that you're up here
so i'm going to do them in alphabetical
order so councillor alban
yeah councillor ashby
here councillor baker prison
councillor dexter
no not president okay i'll come back to
that counselor everett
here that's the oven here
yes councillor rizeki present
that's the piper here
that's the rob president
that's david saunders here councillor
maeve saunders
president
oh present yeah cool councillor right
here okay so council dexter just
confirmed that council dexter is not
with us uh yep no he's not
okay thank you ever so much for that um
there are no counselors that have
indicated that they wish to speak on the
council procedural 20.1 so i'll move
straight on to the excellent chairman
purpose of the meeting is to elect a
chair to serve the remainder of the
2020-2021 municipal year
members may wish to note that the
following members are not eligible to
stand for this election so that's the
chairman of council the vice chair of
council and any other member who is the
chair of another standing committee
of the council so do i have a nomination
for chairman
councillor ashby is his counselor piper
i'd like to recommend councillor ashby
i'll second that proposal nick david
saunders
are there any other nominations for
german
look i'll say that as a no then so as
there is only one candidate
uh i therefore declare that council
ashby has been elected as
uh chairman of the general purposes
committee for the remainder of the
2021 musical year so
um councillor ashby over to you
for uh just the apologies
and then we'll finish the meeting
thank you nick uh thank you committee
members for
um my election um i
i presume we haven't received any
apologies for absence nick
so okay um
well obviously um cancer dexter i'm not
sure i hadn't heard anything myself so
um he will have to be marked as not
present
so and i believe that concludes the
meeting
thank you thank you